just over a hundred days since tragedy
unfolded in these grounds the pain is
still fresh as the community Mourns the
young lives lost on October 1st after
some fans ran onto the pitch that night
police fired 45 rounds of tear gas
including at the stands that triggered
panic and Spectators rushed for the
exits only to find many locked many fans
suffocated in the crush one of the
victims was 17 year old rafano altazira
met his family in a hospital waiting
room hours after the tragedy they were
still hoping he would recover but he
died after 20 days in hospital
I am devastated his mother his siblings
we all feel so guilty if we could turn
back the time we would stop him from
going to the match
five men including three police
officials are now on trial in Surabaya
on charges of negligence the parents of
the victims are reflecting on what they
want now
what I want is for it to be over swiftly
with a clear outcome so Milan can have a
normal life that's what I want as a
father of a victim so my son can be
happy in heaven
a verdict is not expected for weeks or
even months the suspects include the
head of the organizing committee for the
match and the police who gave the orders
to fire cheer gas in the stadium they've
been charged with negligence resulting
in death and could face up to five years
in jail if found guilty
football is one of the most popular
sports in Indonesia but some say it has
been improperly managed for years
putting fans at risk
the Indonesian Football Association they
don't care enough about safety safety
checks are done but not properly
wiona lost his 22 year old daughter Vera
and is following the triumph
I don't hate the police but mistakes
must be punished that's all I ask that's
called Justice
he often reminisces about her graduation
day the ceremony was just a few months
before she died now he says he wants
those responsible for what happened to
her to be held to account Jessica
Washington Al Jazeera Jakarta